let's give you our Subaru in the groove  results.this I insist it was a good play  wasn't it although the butiful cascading  that you suggested was awful good  badonkadonk the Donner bone Mets no what  does that mean the dunker dump my donkey  dong but no I think I'll explain that to  you off there okay done a sneeze knows  what it is it's a big booty Duty  okay aren't you glad you asked  [Music]  yeah Dempsey probably knows what a  badonkadonk is right naps I mean of  course I but yeah I mean listen I those  all of those were really really good had  a lot of fun yesterday kind of  brainstorming through those ideas but I  loved them all including the badonkadonk  yeah how do you think I did explaining a  badonkadonk pretty good pretty good  judy judy is a pretty accurate that's  the kind of the kind you want to see  it's all good I loved it I loved it it  was a fun great storming session inner  inner